[Musique]
on va fabriquer des préparations qui
n'existent pas dans le commerce et qui
sont totalement en fait adaptés à soit
un enfant soit un animal et qui nous
sont demandés soit par un médecin soit
par un vétérinaire en fait et qu'on fait
extemporanément c'est-à-dire au moment
où la personne en a besoin
on pourra jamais rivaliser avec la
quantité produite par l'industrie
pharmaceutique mais l'industrie
pharmaceutique il faut qu'il fasse les
mélanges qui fassent des vides de chêne
qui prépare tout et ça ça prend des
semaines et des semaines alors que nous
on fera beaucoup moins mais on fera tout
de suite
[Musique]
là je vais ouvrir les gélules dans cette
machine là
donc là vous avez les bouchons et là
vous avez les portes des vélos
voilà une fois que j'ai mis toutes ma
poudre je vais fermer les gélules
et je clipse les gélules
[Musique]